Venice Beach with all the weirdos I
guess I'm one of them because I'm
blogging Perry pile legend of the
brofist is still number one
take that Dora the explora you [ __ ]
much there we going soon well more time
for me to play my own game damn it
Maya now Edgar farts no great I suck at
my own game so what do you think about
your game this is the best game I have
ever played so now we are going to the
Venice canals cuz we thought they look
cool and I don't know we just want to
check them up we're here
I guess that's why they call it Venice
so why are we here exactly Marzia you
don't know you hate better place oh my
god that's so crazy the poor thing is
still alive and it's stuck in a
spiderweb oh my god
pretty sure they're sea monsters here
these shots are so annoying because I
always have to go back and get the
camera I just think like every shot in a
blog is like this you know wants
something different I'm sorry I'm trying
would you swing me here really cool
house is here this tree is so done with
life I would be too if I was a tree
Venice Beach with all the weirdos I
guess I'm one of them because I'm
blogging I'm so tired of walking oh my
god we need to find a restaurant I'm
dead we're not gonna make it back hey
did we get free ice cream now no worth a
shot
hmm
what would you write in ten out of ten
baby wow that's good [ __ ] first time is
stuff that by the beach their stuff
doesn't get stolen oh my god
this looks disgusting - what is this you
like this it comes to waves whoa
you crazy girl I can't walk in this so
sweet
just watch it wash away just like I love
gone forever just like that
no I'm not now I'm going I'm going
see ya such a loser
ten minutes my day will start because
we're starting early today I thought
I'll waste some time just doing some
signings I actually really enjoyed doing
signings cuz it's oddly therapeutic and
I know someone will be very happy for it
so that's cool I got like half of them
done
I gotta go they're ringing by the door
marks am i right all right all right
and calming food upon it's too hot it
can do I have to climb today can I just
go around no look at my hair
you've been through war Shh today was
the craziest day out of all the shooting
days for sure uh my body hurts
everywhere going back fall again and get
dinner haven't eaten yet Oh God jaywalk
okay
there's so much fun can't wait for your
brush to seat
Maris is not feeling well so I'm gonna
pick up some stuff for her some such a
good boyfriend by the way look at my
hands
what did i do today no one knows a lot
of people no but it was really cool I'm
still like [ __ ] yeah can't wait can't
wait to show you its 9:57 I haven't
eaten yet
I got Martha's and stuff hopefully it
will help couldn't find any fruit how's
it going guys great
hello ho in LA just because I'm vlogging
I'm the weirdo okay
today was a super long day now I'm gonna
go right back to sleep and sleep right
away not massage anyone what are you
gonna do well I'm sorry
Marcia's pet okay here we go
alright today went by so fast I don't
know what happened it's crazy having a
lot of fun now I'm gonna sleep because
today tomorrow we're having crazy day as
well so what am i a no kiss hold up your
hands give her your energy come on holy
holy [ __ ]
this is a cinema
hell